Andrew Schultz went on the full sun
podcast nine months ago but the episode
never came out for a hilarious reason
Schultz roasted the co-host of the show
so badly that the nelk boys decided none
of it could be posted online in fact the
episode has still never been seen by the
public eye but according to Kyle from
nelk stymie and Schultz were going at
each other for a majority of the episode
and the argument was described as a
heated verbal exchange can we maybe take
certain things out and we could put it
out it's still unknown what exactly
started their back and forth but there's
a good chance that Andrew will be
returning to the show in the near future
to clear the air and watch back the
clips